our solar system is a Savage place from
the ice volcanoes of Saturn's moon
Enceladus to the vast lava fields of
Jupiter's
IO to our own world the Earth volcanoes
destroy but they also create is
literally true that if there weren't
volcanoes here we would not be here
either volcanoes shape and change our
climate volcanos are The Giver of Life
and also the takers of
Life today's space probes and telescopes
reveal volcanoes on worlds we once
thought
dead finding volcanoes on an object
that's smaller than our own moon was a
huge
shock if volcanoes exist on other worlds
could we find life there
[Applause]
too
[Music]
planet Earth a jewel in the darkness of
space our home is
timeless
beautiful and incredibly
violent volcanoes are one of the most
powerful natural phenomena on the
planet they create new land destroy the
old they blast out gases that transform
the air we
breathe deep in our oceans volcanic heat
fuels Strange New
Life volcanoes help power The Living
Earth now we search for signs of Life on
alien
worlds we know life needs water we know
it needs
energy and that's where volcanoes come
in they pump out vast amounts of
energy find volcanos on other
worlds and we might find
life
[Music]
the search Starts
Here the planet orbiting closest to
Earth Venus a world that appears very
much like
ours Venus and Earth are roughly the
same mass they're roughly the same
distance away from the Sun so they're
kind of like
[Music]
twins 3 billion years ago Earth and
Venus were very
[Music]
similar new land new oceans an
atmosphere both planets were perfect for
life but on Venus something went
wrong
something made Venus diverge radically
from the history of the earth Venus took
a definite turn to the dark side a long
time ago Venus is a
hellhole our evil
twin today Venus's surface is like a
furnace it's 900° F on the surface and
it's hot enough to melt actually some
metals so you would stand a
chance Venus is a greenhouse world its
atmosphere is thick with carbon
dioxide it traps heat from the Sun like
a
blanket these actual images of Venus's
surface reveal a Barren superheated Wast
land Venus's thick blanket of CO2
killed the
[Music]
planet the CO2 came from
volcanoes orbiting space probes gave the
first
[Music]
Clues radar punched through Venus's
thick
[Music]
clouds and revealed volcanic formation
across the
[Music]
planet like formations we also see right
here on
Earth the shield volcanoes of
[Music]
Hawaii shield volcanoes get their name
from their round flat
[Music]
shape these volcanoes ooze
but they ooze for thousands of
[Music]
years once we were able to map the
entire surface of Venus using Cloud
penetrating radar we started to study
the land forms there and we saw a lot
that was actually very familiar in
particular we saw giant shield volcanoes
that are very similar to the shield
volcanoes here in
Hawaii the radar images of Venus were
dead ringers for the shield volcanoes on
Hawaii
sometime in the past Venus had
volcanoes for the first time we had a
picture of Venus revealed and boy were
we shocked we found a scarred surface a
volcanic
surface there are at least a thousand
volcanoes that are very large and maybe
tens or even hundreds of thousands of
smaller
ones 3/4 of Venus's surface is lava
Plains evidence of an ancient
cataclysm this could have been a home
for
Life instead it was engulfed by
fire volcanoes belched trillions of tons
of carbon dioxide into Venus's
atmosphere temperatur soared the Seas
boiled dry a runaway greenhouse process
began on Earth carbon dioxide is able to
absorb into the Rocks it's able to
absorb into the ocean but on Venus you
have no water and it's now so hot that
carbon dioxide can't even combine with
the Rocks so as carbon dioxide was
released into the atmosphere by
volcanoes a long time ago over time
there was less and less of a method to
take it back out of the
atmosphere
if Venus ever had life volcanoes
sterilized the entire
world Earth Remains The Only Living
World we know
of that may
change this is the gas giant Jupiter its
moons Frozen and
dead we're so we
thought look closer and a mystery
emerges a cloud hanging over a cold
lifeless
[Music]
World on Venus volcanoes turned an
earthlike world into a superheated
hell finding volcanoes on an earthlike
world was no
surprise but spotting volcanoes on a
moon that was a
[Music]
shock in March
1979 the Voyager 1 space probe gave us
our first close-up view of Jupiter's
Tiny Moon
IO a world we once thought L cold and
dead and they saw something really weird
they saw this Ark next to the moon and
and it looked almost as if like there
was another Moon behind it and we
scratched our heads and said well what
could that be everybody knows that IO is
dead boring uninteresting and then
people realize oh my God it's a volcanic
eruption we found that it's covered with
volcanoes is tremendously geologically
active there are volcanoes erupting all
the time and what they're erupting is a
lot of sulfur and it gets it gets very
hot and sulfur when it changes
temperature changes color it can be red
or orange or yellow or black and so
these pictures of the face of IO make it
look like a pizza covered with different
kinds of cheese and olives where the
little black spots
are IO is not
dead it's alive and
kicking it has over 400 active
volcanoes the largest P erupts from a
gigantic Lava
Lake it reaches nearly 250 miles into
space if we could stand on the edge of
that lava lake and watch that plume
shooting off into the Blackness of space
that would be an incredible
sight
P's eruptions are so huge because IO is
so
small there's nothing to hold the lava
back virtually no atmosphere and very
little
gravity these vast eruptions make earth
volcanoes look like
firecrackers
how can such a tiny moon be so
volcanic the answer is
Jupiter just as the moon raises tides in
Earth's oceans Jupiter raises tides on
iO tides of solid
[Music]
rock io's orbit around Jupiter is not a
circle sometimes it's closer sometimes s
farther
away Jupiter gives IO a gravitational
pounding and so Jupiter's gravity pulls
on it a little bit harder and a little
bit weaker and what happens is the moon
stretches like this it's called a tidal
force and it doesn't stretch this much
it's only a little bit but in fact it's
enough to heat it up it's it's just
friction it's the same way when you rub
your hands together really fast they
begin to feel warm friction creates
heat Jupiter's gravity stretches and
squeezes
ion in every 2-day orbit the ground
Rises and Falls by nearly 300
[Music]
ft this pummeling generates intense heat
and gigantic
pressure wherever there's a weak part in
the crust the lava rushes out so the
volcanism is on a planetary scale unlike
here on Earth where there are certain
that are active around the plates or in
weak spots this is an entire Moon that's
one active Hot
Spot thanks to the incredible power of
gravity IO is the most volcanically
active world in the solar system the
volcanism on iO taught us something new
it taught us that internal sources of
energy can drive vulcanism in a way
that's different from that on Earth in
out of space tidle forces the differ
ential squeezing of the moons of a gas
giant can also create volcanic activity
that was a
GameChanger IO is a lava world
superheated and violent it's hard to
imagine anything surviving
There Yet the volcanic principle here is
the same as on
Earth pressurized superheated magma
below the surface blasts through
fissures in the
crust but not all volcanoes need
magma they don't even need to be
hot travel out past Jupiter and into the
outer solar system and it gets cold
cold really
cold the distant Moon Triton is so cold
that much of its tenuous atmosphere can
freeze
solid and yet there are volcanoes
here volcanoes that may hold the secret
of alien
life